[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the political editors of the daily
mirror and the sun pippa kurara and
harry cole
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the telegraph leads on boris johnson's
address to the ukrainian parliament
tomorrow when the prime minister will
reiterate britain's support for its
people and announce a new 300 million
pound package of military aid
and the times there the headliner rising
inflation to blow seven thousand pounds
hole in pensions
the male has found that there's
such a shortage of gps that doctors in
some communities are being forced to
care for more than 2 000 patients each
the metro understands that a man
masquerading as a priest who also
happened to be a test pilot for ejector
seats successfully managed to stay
overnight in the barracks next to
windsor castle having convinced staff
there that his story was real
and the financial times hears that the
chip maker arm has secured the prime
minister's support to allow it to be
traded on the london stock exchange
rather than in new york
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by pippa
kurara and harry cole welcome to you
both let's start with the
telegraph and uh boris johnson the prime
minister's address to ukrainian
parliament uh johnson ukraine is ready
for its finest hour
pippa
yes so uh the news obviously uh on the
front page of the telegraph and several
other papers is that russ johnson's
going to address the ukrainian
parliament you'll remember that a few
weeks ago president zielenski addressed
the house of commons in a similar
address and has
also spoken to the european parliament
and congress in the states boris johnson
is going to be the first western leader
to speak to the ukrainian parliament um
it's not going to be live address
obviously the security issues around
that
um uh sort of be pre-recorded but uh the
symbolism of him uh speaking as uh the
first western leader
would be lost to lots of people i'm sure
he has made a sort of a major point
conservatives made a major point about
the fact that he has been the most
proactive as they see it amongst western
leaders certainly in the early stages of
the invasion in terms of sort of that
support for
ukraine and uh interesting to see the
telegraph in just the second paragraph
refers to him echoing winston churchill
now boris jones will be very pleased
with that obviously he's a big fan of
winston churchill and his rhetoric and
uh he's channeling the sort of the
finest hour speech which you'll remember
was the famous churchill speech from the
1940s which he appealed to britain to
keep on fighting hitler even in the dark
days
he'll be channeling that when he speaks
the ukrainians however the timing
shouldn't be lost on us i mean it's
quite fortuitous shall we say that boss
johnson is able to make this speech and
remind everybody of probably the sort of
the one
big area that's going really well for
him at the moment in terms of being seen
as a as a strong leader for the the
our
ukraine
to the ukraine conflict when it's just a
couple of days out from the local
elections
obviously quite happy to be front pages
on anything other really than the cost
of you know steering away from the cost
of living crisis from partygate which
obviously difficult territory both of
those we can't see harry at the moment
but he's uh he's shaking his head and
he's laughing uh what exactly
what are you suggesting
i'm not sure president zielenski and the
ukrainian parliament's diaries are
necessarily dictated around uh around
the uh british uh municipal town hall
election cycle um i suspect that was
probably good fortune rather than uh
rather than anything else but um yeah i
agree with pippa it is it is
back on his strongest
suit at the moment um but i think timing
must be purely coincidental rather than
it being some sort of election uh
election push
um
well i mean i don't know the details of
who asked who did the ukrainians ask
forrest johnson or was it the other way
around put it this way whichever way the
invitation went whichever way the
request went i'm sure they've been quite
happy to seize the opportunity to speak
to the parliament
i know about half a billion pounds worth
of weapons and uh and support on top of
various other economic
packages probably does buy you a ticket
to uh to address the parliament um i
don't think that's really
really really room for any criticism
beyond coincidental timing
how significant do you think it is
though for the the prime minister to be
seen on the the international stage to
be back in in ukraine and addressing the
parliament
i don't think we need to be looking at
this really through a prism of of how
useful it is to boris johnson i think
it's more how useful is it the ukrainian
parliament and
any move we had uh the u.s um
congress speaker in uh in in kiev over
the weekend
um we you know any move that shows the
west
powerful western leaders
fully behind ukraine and not only saying
we are fully behind you but now actually
this your finest hour is inside you can
carry on pushing and we will give you
the resources to keep pushing the
russians back i think that is a major
boost for for the ukrainians at a time
when actually the the the fate of this
of this war is on the turn and you know
it it it is a time to put the the metal
the pedals pedal to the floor and
actually increase the amount of support
that the ukrainians have because you
know
imagine us saying on the 24th of
february um sitting on this tv channel
saying that we think the ukrainians
could drive russians back um you know
we've been laughed at we'd been deluded
but that's what it looks like could
happen and we need as much support as
they can possibly get let's turn to the
the support that we're giving to
ukrainian refugees or not uh as it were
the guardian has an article about the
home secretary facing legal action from
ukrainians who who are stuck in this um
so-called visa backlog the delays that
have left thousands of ukrainians um in
limbo pippa
yes i mean
as well as the military response which
uh harry rightly flags military support
for ukraine the other big way that
britain has responded to the crisis is
to open its doors to uh potentially
hundreds of thousands of ukrainian
refugees and 74 000 people 75 000 people
have applied so far to homes of ukraine
system but only 15 of them have so far
been granted so far arrived now part of
that is sort of the you know
the bureaucratic um
morass that is the home office uh is you
know it takes a huge amount of time to
process these applications children in
particular obviously very vulnerable but
their applications take longer and part
of it seems to be according to the
guardian the fact that even if
some of these visas have been processed
the applicants haven't yet been informed
so people who are already incredibly
traumatized having to make a decision as
to whether they stay put in eastern
europe where they currently are or
whether they go back to
um they go back to ukraine even at risk
of further uh violence at the hands of
the russians they sort of said many of
them are are in this state of limbo and
uh various groups are considering legal
action and judicial reviews against the
home office uh really for for promising
so much and delivering so little and the
contrast that the guardian makes is
between britain which is which is an
outlier really um in europe in terms of
uh requiring visa routes for people that
are fleeing ukraine there's two
different sponsorship groups as i'm sure
your viewers are aware uh with pretty
much every other country including
ireland are our closest geographic
neighbor which don't have those visa
routes uh obviously there's reasons that
britain's decided not least that we're
not in the european union security
reasons and so on we've decided to have
those systems in place but it does show
how complicated that then can make it to
get people here and and the one thing i
think we'd all agree on is that there's
been an overwhelming outpouring of
support from british people opening
their doors opening their homes wanting
to help ukrainian people and so far the
government bureaucracy is uh is stalling
that and that's that's obviously a worry
yeah um and harry would you say that the
government has over-promised and
under-delivered it in terms of helping
ukrainian refugees
yeah i don't you can really escape that
as pippa says the the gap between
the
rhetoric and the
um compassion of the british public is
not being met by the
um by the by the schemes that said it is
a lot better than it was
four weeks ago it is you know it's a
scheme set up from scratch um it is
getting there you know the numbers that
are being processed are you know were
woeful to begin with but it is being
took over i think this lawsuit is
probably more of a press release than an
actual legal case um and it's about
raising the profile it's about keeping
the keeping the plight of the of
refugees on the front pages it's about
raising awareness of the of
the problems still yeah the idea that
this is going to actually get end up in
a tangible
win or solution or or fix this problem
it it it's just not really for the birds
it's very detailed it's very detailed
light it's you know
considering league of legends looking at
judicial views okay if you look at
talking about your bureaucratic bogging
down of a process trying to get uh
trying to go into the british courts
right now in the post covert backlog is
uh you know that's bureaucracy like no
one's ever seen so i think it's a good
bit of pr but whether this ever actually
ends in any real legal action of any
meaningful um result
remains to be seen yes we shall see
although the article does say a class
action lawsuit is being prepared but as
you say we shall see if that comes to
fruition uh let's move to the mail and
this back to uh the refugee crisis in
terms of the channel crossings and the
question the article is really asking is
is the rwanda plan working because we're
still seeing high numbers of people
trying to to get into the uk via the
channel
pippa
well not yet i mean there was this
astonishing day period where there were
no channel crossings and the reaction
amongst some uh sanctorium p's but some
sort of you know people on the right uh
campaigners like nigel farage
and and others uh was one of it was
really sort of you know to stress that
this looks like that the rwanda scheme
which was ultimately designed to be
deterrent people crossing the channel um
was working but of course at the same
time we were getting weather reports
saying that you know it was incredibly
windy and very dangerous conditions and
we have previously had
you know periods of a couple of weeks at
a time where there's been no crossings
because it's not being regarded as safe
to do so and it now looks like that this
last 10 days has been one of those
periods as well and it's not in fact a
sudden realization by all those people
in uh refugee camps and and sort of in
the sand dunes of of north east france
um waiting you know being put off
because they might be deported to uh to
rwanda it was in fact about the weather
and we've seen 300 people or so i think
the world navy are saying coming over um
over the weekend and it just underlies
really the scale of the problem there's
you know there's an issue of if people
smugglers and the fact that the
government is desperate to tackle the
inhumane dangerous reckless um
illegal practice of of uh you know
taking large amounts of money from
people and putting them on a really
perilous journey in which many lose
their lives
with the fact that that
britain also wants to ultimately um
it feels to me
have as a hostile uh
system for asylum seekers as possible
and the rwandan system
was announced by pretty patel despite
pressure from her own civil servants at
the home office uh they she had an issue
ministerial direction because they
thought it would be value for money they
thought it'd be subject to legal
challenge and they thought that it
actually might be impossible to
implement and you know today as we've
seen hundreds of people coming over the
channel i think increasingly it's a
reminder that it's going to be really
hard for them actually
we're running out of time let's just say
one quick line from harry
yeah i think anyways anyone that was
going to say on both sides of this
argument was a bit of a hostage to
fortune it was you know high winds in
the channel um for the last 11 days but
there is a it is a little a little
strange how suddenly lots of people who
who really didn't care about this issue
for a very long time um and now you know
studying every single wind change
direction in the channel and you know
the more the merrier this is a serious
issue it's one of the most uh one of the
top issues to the british public at the
top of their concerns um but you know
there's a lot of johnny come lately's
now who's suddenly in the last 11 days
developed expertise on channel crossings
to go no no no no it's not working but
that's the point you need some radical
solutions to to try and break this harry
and pippa for the moment thank you we
must take a break coming up is labour
operating under a double standard over
allegations sakirstama drank beer with
staff during lockdown we'll be
discussing that next
[Music]
press preview still with me pippa
and harry cole let's take a look at uh
the mail
the quote there the headline no
reasonable person believes labour's
story who's saying that and uh what's it
about
harry
so
kirsten has uh been quite um
fortunate really that durham police have
not taken quite such a hard line on
fairly minor lockdown breaches as
perhaps someone like rishi sunak who you
know uh well walked into a work meeting
and there was a small celebration going
on to mark the prime minister's birthday
and you end up getting slapped with a 50
pound fine what you might put at the
extreme end of lockdown enforcement yet
there's pictures as we
put your viewers we will verse with now
of course thomas sinking a beer at 10
o'clock at night on a friday night and
he said that he was having a small break
before going back to work now
nadine doris uh one of the prime
minister's most vocal defenders um
especially on twitter has been out and
about saying look no one believed that
we've got former metropolitan police
officers saying actually the law doesn't
seem to be being applied both in you
know in durham as it is in london and
it's all shaping up to be a bit of a
mess and just like boris johnson i
suspect
if kierstarma or boris johnson right at
the early days when the first
revelations came out they they put their
hands up and apologized and said yes we
probably shouldn't have done that it
probably was a bit of a grayer sorry you
know we're sorry
um they probably would have you know
taken the sting out of this but star
wars but this is this is the second time
around though isn't it because this this
was um well
you know police had a look at this
before and
police said they were gonna they weren't
gonna look durham police very clearly
said they weren't going to look at
historic allegations and stuck to the
line that was the original metropolitan
police line until public pressure
made them actually go back and have a
look at the the the the rule breaking
down industry kyostama is saying the
police have investigated this and found
nothing's wrong they haven't actually
they just said they weren't going to
investigate it now it obviously it's an
election week but since mr sunic has
been fined there has been a a sort of
quite valid
point made by lots of people from
various not just the tories but
commentators as well that actually the
law doesn't seem to be being applied
when clearly i think star wars could
pretty much bang to rights in that
photograph that he shouldn't have been
inside drinking during during stage two
what do you think is this really because
the the tories have pushed for this to
be reopened uh because
as as we've said it was decided the
first time around that there wasn't a
case to answer
i think harry gets the absolute nub of
it when he says that this is election
week you know this first story first
came out as harry said last may i think
it was in the sun
and uh the police decided not to
investigate at that point during police
and here we are you know a year later
and it suddenly erupted into a story
again it's been on the front page of the
mail four days in a row i think it's the
the fifth is finally the day that
they've not splashed on it and i think
it's really interesting actually in
terms of like the media story here um
the mail's under new editorship they
clearly are much more
supportive of boris johnson than the
previous editor was
they want to do some favors here because
he is in trouble over partygate and i
think when you get to the detail of it
um i think there's a question about
equivalence and i i absolutely take
harry's point about rishi sinha
however i think comparing uh kyo stamina
and boris johnson
but no one is saying that
multiple events which she described as
work events pre-organize bring your own
boost parties christmas parties festive
quizzes leaving dues
at which 50 fines have already been
issued and more probably on the way
including possibly for the prime
minister it's not equivalent and uh it
feels very much to me like sort of
campaigning ahead of the elections in an
attempt to kind of muddy the waters and
hire everybody of the same russian
policy
i would love to have seen your reaction
i would love to have seen your reaction
if boris johnson had come out and said
the reason that he lied about partygate
which he clearly has told miss truth
about it along the way was because he
was too busy to know the facts i mean
come on he used some pretty crap excuses
harry harry we'll have to excuse your
your language then shall we move should
we move on to um the metro just got time
to talk about this story and this is to
do with it um a quite significant
security breach at windsor castle how
are you kick us off
uh i promise i don't swear this time but
yes another
another long list in the blunders of um
of royal security look there's all sorts
of nutters that obviously try to break
into palace's royal palaces all the time
and like the old old adage that the
security services only have to get lucky
they have to be lucky every time the
nutter only has to be lucky once it
looks like someone has slipped through
the net but a very worrying one that's
developing tonight yeah pippa just takes
into a bit more of the detail of this
bridge of security
well um so i don't know a huge amount
about this this story so harry might be
better equipped to bring us up to bring
us up in the detail but um i believe
somebody uh managed to pass themselves
off a fake priest
um ended up spending the night in winter
castle after calling one of the queen's
bodyguards um uh and uh obviously winter
castle is where the queen is he spent
the night eating and drinking and the
officer's mess
somehow managed to convince people that
he was a friend
of uh the regiment's priest and um he
was even offered breakfast the next
morning
and it was only after eventually it was
uncovered and the police arrived at the
barracks uh but yeah you know he spent
almost uh 16 hours uh with with the
troops eating in the office's mess we
must leave it there thank you both we'll
see you